[Music]
hello everybody welcome to another
evening of wednesday fun
maybe we should actually change it to
wednesday weirdos because we're actually
going to be talking about weird lines as
sicilian today
this is no longer just on psychology
this is weird sicilian
um
i think so far that has been my best
opening in these wednesday classes but
all right we have few in-person audience
that i don't think i know even if i do
the mask will not help me
um chess boondo is missing we should
call him up see if he's all right all
right um
so i really wanted to do like a opening
series and we started doing it from last
week
we liked it we liked seeing those
openings from last week but
i struggled deciding on should i go for
like main main lines or should i still
keep it to the weird lines first so the
suspenses build up and then we hit like
big lions and con or
in dragon or night or so we have few
cool ones coming up
um
oh i see some
heists from different countries all
right let's go ahead and just jump right
into it we can catch up later
oh i see fake more essentially in the
chat too welcome
all right
um so these are some of my own
experiences uh in this
line so these are actually my games
probably i was too young
and inexperienced in some of these but
uh if i'm not mistaken one or two of
them did score me the asian youth
championship
so i'm not complaining
um the first weird line that i want to
mention was this knight of six knight of
six is by no means wrong or bad or
anything but how it followed was a
little
unorthodox
usually this a6 is more desired this
knight c6 is kind of played if you go
knight to f6 then you're probably going
to go for d6 and get into chaveningen
which is something we will talk about
not this week
so
knight f6 was played i went normal i got
the night out bishop d3 is also another
possibility for those of you who like
bishop d3 so knight c3 my opponent went
through night
these set of opponents went for knight
c6
and all right so this is actually called
if i'm not mistaken the four knights in
sicilian which makes
absolutely no sense to me
but a lot of players like it a lot of
players play it there's nothing wrong
with it you just have to know how to
play it so as white
my first question for my in person and
online audience
what should we do
okay i see a fragrance saying
bring this here i like it
now taking taking doesn't do much for it
so they can take with the b push here
this is it
oh somebody says e5 after knight f6 hold
on hold on i'm gonna actually scroll
back if you play e5 you will have made
your opponent extremely happy
because drum roll please
check
and bye bye pawn
so
if you're in a generous mood and you
want to make your opponents happy e5 is
the way
so
these four knights getting developed
then knight b5
so bishop b4 is the most common one
there is this weird well not i don't
want to say weird for everything but
right now kind of everything feels weird
to me so
sorry
uh d6 is a possibility but then you can
play bishop before and then get yourself
into these positions which are again
the very very um
common cevishnikov ones so that's
another thing we'll talk about later not
today because that's another humongous
line
so
um
it can't transpose the beauty of
sicilian does transposes to everything
so let's say opponent actually doesn't
want to transpose there and they go
bishop b4
what do you think we should do after
bishop b4
oh fragrance it seems like you know your
stuff 96 is a possibility that i do not
support
i actually did it once or twice it was
very uncomfortable you just kind of help
opponents develop
you don't really do anything for them
you know you don't really do anything to
them
they have they still have um
attacking stuff they can easily try to
do like a fake castle you don't have any
good follow-up after that
so that's not that's not gonna that's
not gonna cut it
not knight d6 a3 is a good idea now
black will take idaho will take
and it's kind of funny because i
actually left myself a little mental
notes because i actually do know this
opening very well because years ago by
when i played tournaments in iran
because i lived there
this opening became so
popular for no good reason just like
everybody from the north of the country
had like same coach and everybody would
play it's like how the fright liver is
so common in kids in us
because when i came here i'm sure i've
said this ten thousand times when i came
here fried liver is not i didn't know
fried liver was a thing as a chest i
thought it was a
food but
um
so keeping yeah actually it's kind of
funny i do know at least i prepared my
brother against him because they're
similar age
so they would play in the same age group
so i prepared my brother against him
then similar opening and i think my
brother got a draw or had a winning
position but
anyways um that was kind of fun but
that's what i'm saying like because
alireza is also from the north part of
the iran so it was kind of funny to see
that like everybody from the north side
of iran is playing that
okay so
um now d5 is a good choice kind of only
choice
take take bishop castle castle and now
there are multiple different ways that
black can play it there's this d4
there's this bishop g4
and
so keeping those in mind
let's say opponent goes d4
actually yeah let's go up one let's say
opponent goes d4 then what do you do
d4 is the main one so what we're going
to do right now is first we're going to
look at like the main one of this weird
lines then we're going to kind of come
back and look at some of the sidelines
that could have done
so
d4
you kind of gotta go knight e2 i agree
now i've had multiple opponents play
different things somebody played h6
somebody played bishop g4
somebody
could have done rookie 8 i'm sure they
did it too
thank you
thank you
smirky pants
the main weird lines and the weird weird
ones exactly
i just want an opening called weird
just literally i just want that
out there because
the word weird is so weirdly cool that
the translation in frc is not as weirdly
cool it's just like
there
so the word weird is cool for me because
also the first
year that i was using it i kept typing
it as wired so
after a while i realized that that's not
how it's
spelled so
all right
let's talk about bishop g4
okay bishop g4 what what you gonna do
you're getting pinned you have few
choices you can ignore it you can
resolve it
yeah uh sorry all i'm not gonna do those
h4a4 no no no it still has to be defined
as opening for me the h4a4 those stuff i
don't consider them openings i'd
consider them just
moves so as long as they're you know
part of a
normal opening and then it can deviate
into the weirdness we like it
i actually took a
course
last semester and that's for my
healthcare takes minor called
um freaks it was a cool course
the name really really spoke to me
anyways
yep we gotta go for f3
they have to move the bishop so let's
say bishop h5 now what do we do we have
a few options
i'm particularly fond of
one of them but right now i don't want
to talk about moves i want this to
actually take a minute
and think
what is going on in this position
because we are kind of like
in a stage that there are multiple
things that should be considered
for example we have two bishops
another example we played f3 so their e3
square is you know
um
squeaky
uh opponent has isolated pawn on d4 so
that would be a nice target so there are
multiple factors that
we should think before making a decision
on
how to continue our development
so i see moves already
but i don't think that's what we're
going for
okay i see bishop g5 ideas possibly
knight to four ideas there's this really
really
weird b4 that i've also
encountered personally i like like b4
bishop b2 stuff to just start attacking
that pawn but personally if i have to
attack this pawn i would much rather do
it
this way
rather than b4 b4 just feels like i'm
i don't know the e3 square just gets too
weak
so
instead of that
um what i would like to think about is
bishop g5
i would also like to mention that
knight f4 is totally doable nothing
wrong with it
but if bishop g6 you're kind of
committed into taking taking and then
what
kids are cute
um we can play bishop g5 we can go f4
but you know you kind of lost that
key attacker on d4 so it makes a lot of
sense to keep your key attacker on d4 so
the knight on e2
and
if you nobody's taking that this bishop
is going nowhere so if you wanted to
continue attacking that bishop with
knight f4 with knight g3 you are more
than welcome to do that later so i like
bishop g5
ah that's a very good point smirky pants
this is definitely a position where i
would be stuck for a plan i agree that's
what we're talking about because it's a
weird position it's a very unorthodox if
you've never seen it before you're just
going to sit there and just
call different
gods for help so
bishop g5
there are multiple things that black can
do black can do a rookie edge could do
like a bishop g6 could do like queen d6
and etc because i actually have a very
ginormous file on this that hurts me
when i look at it so i did not actually
include this here because
the less headache the better
one of the big mistakes that i made
growing up was i loved engines so i just
kind of like clicked that space whenever
they were analyzing which was fine but
then i ended up with like a 30 000 move
file and then i was like okay now we
gotta trim but i didn't want to trim
because you know i spent so much time on
energy actually doing those
beautiful analysis
so
try to have more practical files rather
than what i did i had to spend like a
whole year cleaning my files it was not
fun
now i have more decent files but i don't
play as much so
too late i guess anywho
um
let's talk about what if queen d6
because 26 is what happened to me
surprisingly more than once
all right
um
we will also talk about
instead of bishop g4 rook e8 so like 2 3
moves back
after we look at this
one
so
i'm going to tell you what i did because
engine pack went like five actually
seven years ago engine seven years ago
liked it
i don't think engine would dislike it
but i like the logic behind it i played
queen e1
okay engine still doesn't hate it but
this is also not the super engine queen
d2 is very reasonable as well because if
bishop g6 you can just exchange it off
and do rook d1 so now this is a better
target for you but i like queen e1
because i'm kind of keeping my options
open maybe i want to go up here maybe i
just want to settle on f2 maybe i'm just
doing it for the rookie one it was
tricky it was confusing and it made up
on it uncomfortable which is literally
my style to make my plant uncomfortable
there's a question about see-through is
possible i mean i just want to eat this
pawn i don't want to liquidate it so
yeah
definitely a possibility but not one
that i would do
at least without a fight for the full
pawn
all right so after queen e1 my opponents
played bishop g6
rook d1 worked there queen f2
and
now i have a nice little setup on how to
bother this pawn
so
let's say opponent plays rook 2
d8
now what would you do
now this is definitely not the opening
but i definitely have my an analysis and
files
for this game because if i'm not
mistaken this was actually
yeah this was in
asian championship 2013 oh my god eight
years ago uh the second time i won it
and um i was playing um like one of
those like friends with competitive
competitors that i always play every
single year
so i i knew what she played she knew
what i played this wasn't the first time
we were playing so i just really wanted
to keep my beautiful score against her
um
yeah maybe i should actually check up on
her
anywho
what do you think should happen now
why to move what to do
while we're thinking i also wanted to
say because i'm slightly excited about
this event so i actually want to talk
about it
um the strategy across the border that's
gonna uh that
was held
for like two three years
con
all the time in december again it's
going to be this year last year was
virtual so i couldn't really you know do
as much as i wanted but this year it
will be december 4th so if you are in
saint louis
look it up try to join
it's basically big chess party
there'll be a lot of chess players there
we'll talk about it more later as well
but i just wanted to share my excitement
for this event
okie dokie so rook
d8 ah you want to get knight to g3
possible
you want to try to get your bishop maybe
rolling that way too definitely doable
how about just doubling up
rooks because if rook d7 then easy peasy
now if rookie e5 i had this rook e5 as
like a computer game
that then i just you know it helps my
bishop so one of the small things to
learn from this do not help your
opponents
so my opponent didn't help me
unfortunately so she went right d7 i
just doubled these up and here she i
think made the first inaccuracy with
queen c5
which i was
very pleased about
but
the best move would be possibly to take
over here
and then try to kind of figure out
what's happening on that side of the
board
and then this beautiful knight is vibe
to kind of make my bishop tiny tad bit
miserable because i can't move here
they'll take
so it's just stuck here i don't want to
exchange enough but i don't want it to
be there because it's useless there so a
lot of
mental problems as well
um
so
here probably c3 would have been decent
white has a tiny advantage but
converting it at that advantage to an
actual um
something that you can use will be
will take some time and some generous
opponents
so
in the game opponent queen c5 what do
you think we should do right now in this
game
i like what i did then i kind of messed
it up and then i did well but for right
now
what changed from the position
the time kind of just uh whenever you
see where you're looking at a game or
looking at a position kind of just
think about what changed
consider upon his last move a lot of the
times you you might not have a plan but
your opponent's uh does and as if you
can diffuse that plan that's a plan on
its own
i like it yeah let's double these pawns
up
beautiful pawn structure
beautiful i'm loving it
now what do we do
to be fair i messed up in the game a
tiny tad bit but
what do you think would be a
logical
follow-up now
i see f4
i see c3 in the chat
i'll tell you what i think i should have
done
i think i should have gone for something
like b4 to just poke this queen when the
queen moves on f4 and now i want to do
f5 so if you take amazing now my rook is
joining too if you don't take and if you
try to play f5 yourself well you just
made your bishop a tall pawn
congratulations
if you try to defend it that way i would
still have
ideas of my own i'm really tempted for
this f5 too but i don't think it's the
right time just yet because let me show
you actually why not
oh it did too fast first check
then let's say you move the king then
this falls
wait why am i self torturing
let's just go for the queen
and even if you don't even if d3 you
just try to block it take take take
take
take
oh my god so many takes good luck
winning this broken game
so
okay that was too much i don't think um
as soon as you see the move d3 you
should just stop your calculation and go
back because you're not gonna this is
not the the position you want so f5 is
why it's not going to work right now and
we need to kind of follow up um create
more backup for it
okay that was a big load um so b4 would
have been logical knight g3 would have
been very reasonable with the same idea
but i was very impatient and i think i
was actually hungry in the game so i
went for c3 i'm always hungry when i
played chess
um
i think it's a matter of principle at
this point
and my idea was yummy ponds or queens
and of course my opponent didn't blunder
their queen why would they
they simply went for queen b6 which is a
reasonable move but black actually might
have
a rather intriguing tiny tactic here
what do you think is the best move for
black right
now also for those of you who are kind
of uh new to
playing with or against isolated pawns
leeches actually has pretty nice videos
about it i've been recommending those to
people so feel free to check the leaches
video library for those and of course
the sentence chess club youtube and
twitch video libraries for those
but
um you should you should have a pretty
good understanding of how to play
against different pawn structures it
doesn't have to be so deep it doesn't
have to be like analysis but just that
idea
there are books out there too
but
if you want something faster videos will
do it
yes exactly thank you
skull
beautiful name
rook takes e2 queen takes e2 we'll take
it
take this if you move this take that
let's say you take that
c2 oh
yeah
i don't want
no
no
why would i get myself into this
position that i would just have to sit
there and watch how my opponents can
advance their position no you should not
get yourself into dispositions
voluntarily
all right
let's go back
i think that was reason enough for not
c3 but even if opponent doesn't go in
there even with queen b6 it's still
uncomfortable because for example i
chose to take opponent took back and
then i took over here so i have an extra
pawn right that was the goal of c3 to
win that pawn but now opponent gets um
peace activity and i shouldn't have to
give up
um
the chance to
have opponents pieces less active for
just a pawn that'll always be under
attack and it's the target and so
what i did wrong right now was i chose
the wrong way to convert the advantage
so let me go back to your moves here
white has good advantage it's not
winning by any means but white has
advantage white has a special advantage
pawn structure advantage uh
the wait a little i think those two are
the big ones so keeping that in mind i
tried to convert those into material
advantage whereas i could have actually
tried to create an attack out of it
instead
so knight g3 maybe bishop e4 or knight
e4 just trying to push for a better
position rather than push for eating
pawn but what can i do i'm eating
ponzo's in my dna at this point
all right so i ate the pawn opponent is
trying to create some nice counter play
what should i do as white
again by no means white is any worse now
but i kind of let the opponent get a
little happy and that's that's the
problem
being hungry makes you eat ponds
that
probably is true as you can see in this
game
ah d5 is very intriguing but if i play
d5
i'm kind of asking opponent to already
go to an end game with me and i don't
want to dance that dance
the king is weak i wanted to use that
but i also was slightly over ambitious
this is still winning this is still very
winnable for white
because of the extra pawn and the better
space and everything that we just talked
about but i don't want i don't want to
dance the dance i would prefer to play
something a little bit
a little bit less
engine liked
but keep the the keep the queens on
board so i went for rook c2
then opponents decided to
activate their queen which i think was
not good because the queen is actually
kind of good where it is king g7 would
make more sense to try to maybe
bring a rook there or just to bother me
or just to you know put the king in a
better defense
king g7 is actually kind of nice queens
b5 it just helps me i develop mine
knight i develop my night
and now
what do you think is a good idea now
oh this is actually a nice tactic maybe
i should put that on my
i've been thinking about writing another
book just for tactics but the problem is
that i feel discouraged because i also
don't recommend tactic books to people i
just tell them there are so many puzzle
themes out there just go do those so i
don't know how many people would like a
puzzle book if you're one of them
actually leave a comment below and
i'll it will help me um
see if i actually want to do that puzzle
book because
i'm still ready for a second book
is a bit awkward for black i mean black
is
not not having a lot of fun right now
ah aaron lee good job i like this b4
knight moves boom b5 because if you take
haha if you don't take your knight is
gonna be
um
meeting his maker i guess that's one way
to say it
so if queen b5 as she didn't as she did
in the game i went for queen f1 i kind
of
chickened out i should have just eaten
this and i should have eaten this i
don't know why i didn't eat
to this day i don't understand why i
didn't eat okay i went queen f1 is still
just as good
and then she took over here then i did
this i simplified and then i just went
for
the win and it was a very easy win after
that i had no trouble and i think
actually under the circumstances because
i was actually playing for
uh winning a tournament i was playing
for winning asian youth championship so
i wanted to be safe so it kind of
actually made sense to simplify the
position oh trying to give me chickpea
that's cute
so um you know in that situation it
makes sense to not
let your opponent get counter play and
have a safe line secured
okay
there's the safe when that was secured
actually here
and i actually did win that tournament
for a second time
and then i did another year and i won a
third time and i was like you know what
i think i'm good three asian
championship goals i'm i'm good i didn't
play anymore after that then i kind of
changed continents and federations after
that so
yeah i don't think i can actually play
asian championships anymore so let's go
back
i wanted to mention this
here
not actually not here
here
if not turkish uh if not through e7 what
else do you think would be a decent idea
for opponents because we have a pretty
cool attack going on upon us p surge is
just kind of all around
unhappy but
what do you think
am i hearing music am i hallucinating
oh is that why we're up here
well i like scenery
i don't imagine it was too much fun for
you to move stuff around but
all right
now this is this is fun um my opponent
could have done like a rook d ah no the
other one rook d8
so just try to get away from this but
the result is the same i'll still have
a pretty nice advantage wait what if you
take then i can push yeah
easy peasy
okay i'm gonna scroll back
a lot now so bear with me
a lot of scrolling
uh we wanted to mention
there with me bear with me ah a little
bit more
there we go
uh instead of bishop wait no instead
oh my god now
instead of queen d6 there is rook e8 as
well
either right now or before bishop g4
there we go that's what i wanted to get
at so now what do you think we should do
with this if rookie 8 so no bishop g4 no
f3
so where are we
fianchetto well before actually is
surprisingly not bad it's
doable but if bishop g4 then f3 if you
do the f3 again then you have that same
hole issue
um
all right so what else so not b4 is not
a no but
more of a maybe what else do you think
is possible possibility
maybe bishop g5 yeah
all right i'm fine with that actually i
think either one does work pretty neat
neatly whatever
um my english is never gonna be perfect
it's gonna get better and i'm still
gonna come up with my own words so
okay
um
knight
ifrook e8
uh bishop g5 is definitely doable bishop
g4 is to kind of have to take it a
little chill because f3 uh still doable
but you don't have that queenie one
anymore so the the dynamic of it changes
a little so it's very important to have
your openings um
kind of organized up here and in your
laptop because you have to be able to
figure out what to do first how did the
position change what if they do this
move first can i still do what i wanted
so there's actually not c3 because this
is a blunder please don't blunder
the last one was a blunder please don't
oops
anyways uh bishop g5 totally doable but
i'm more fond of d uh b4
and if bishop g4 well first things first
we're not obligated to play f3 we could
simply just play bishop b2 and just
wait on it
so
that is definitely doable
um how about let's say opponent gets too
cute and plays knight d5 what are you
doing then
oh i see in min in the chat one of my
best friend's names is mine
you're not that man are you probably not
he would text me first before showing up
in my stream
all right so what do we do now
if i'm not mistaken the word min
uh means sun
i think
so
different languages i was in vietnam
2008 i liked it i was 10 i don't
remember much but
it was fun
cool food
all right so d4 is something that we
could start to go at
but if you're still uncomfortable with
bishop g4 i would do this queen d4 first
if you do not
wait wait so
you i
what
some people are suggesting this are you
tired of having extra material
i'm glad something
but no because like you kind of gave two
pieces just for a night and a pawn
so
oops
yeah i wouldn't recommend that
how about first chill queen d2
then you can do this then you can want
to do that
now
my opponent actually if i'm not mistaken
it was the same opponent
again
but anywho she went for bishop g4 f3
bishop moves i got the bishop out she
played queen b6 and i went chill king h1
uh
so
we still have this very similar
structure except now there's this weird
knight e3's that i don't like
so i feel like i
this game was before the other game
so the game that we saw first with me
not playing before bishop b2 was like
the improved version of it
so
i'm offering both options to you but
i would kind of vote for not making your
opponent happy by giving the eight
giving them the e3 square so just
something to keep in mind
anyways rook d8 is definitely a
possibility b5 would be cool
knight takes d4 is also doable but now
opponent take a opponent could take
take if take we have this right yes
that's in the chat
people are also
mentioned this discovery attack
previously as well
um but the weird thing is now opponent
can take over here and the rook is open
and i don't i don't want to help my
opponents
get funny with me
so
yeah i don't think uh that is true
instead of f3 h3 is a possibility but
because the
the pin would still be annoying so i
would kind of rather to have this f3
and not b4
have would like bishop g5 rather than
have h3 and b4
but i think that's a personal preference
so if you're comfortable with your um
with opponents bishop and g4
having diagonal that is totally fine
there's no chest thing that's wrong with
it
queen g5
goodness gracious
what if they take this
right yeah this is not fun anymore
all right so not mine takes b4 oh not my
takes d4 what if b5 this is actually
what i did in the game i believe it's
been like nine years oh my god
um i'm writing applications now for
medical school secondaries and well
actually i've been writing them for
quite a while and like every time i'm
talking about in my 17 years of
involvement in chess and i'm just like
17 years old
if i did anything for 17 years
ah
yeah anyways sometimes i complain about
being involved in chess for so long
but it's fun
and i think you're all hooked because
you're all here on a wednesday night so
all right
um yeah opponent went for knight e3
uh it's getting cramped
and i decided to just go for this end
game and i was a
i was a better chess player so i won
this end game
but
the truth of it is that this endgame
should not
be uncomfortable for black
i just exchanged stuff off and somehow
how on god's blue earth did i win this
seriously
should have had a very generous opponent
oh how bad oh my god i'm playing this
bad wait i didn't win it okay that's the
trick we agreed on a joke
no this is a different name this is i
think a training game
but
yeah anyways um yeah i'm
i would be very very lucky if i won that
game that shouldn't have been a thing
okay i'm glad i didn't win that because
that would kind of question my chess
understanding
uh no besides that
so
okay
i think that's we got off on a different
line okay
the the takeaway from this line that i
want you to have is
your opponent right now has a much much
much
easier game
they have a better space better
development better center
better placed pieces and all of your
places are like kind of on the second
rank one on the third rank and your
piece harmony is
practically non-existence so for that
reason i actually don't really recommend
playing um
with b4 there are certain lines where b4
would be useful
uh which we can't talk about a talk upon
or touch upon actually next time too
but
for
most of it b4 is too early you can't
have good piece harmony and your bishop
on g5 is much more useful than
b2 so that's that's
one thing that i definitely want to
mention
i'm not saying b4 is bad or impossible
or don't do it but i'm saying be aware
that your pieces can get
very
disorganized very fast
and it's easy position for opponents
because black just has to you know move
these around
and
defend the pawn black is the one with
the isolated pawn so black has more
space black has better center black has
a possible peace activity that will be
better than yours
but
for the cost of an isolated pawn which
is a permanent
weakness for them and a permanent target
for us
so as long as we don't allow them to
have that peace activity that attack
then we will have a nice time with that
isolated pawn
so
that is the big thing i wanted to go
over now what if
then another game i had someone play h6
which is totally not wrong because they
stopped bishop g5 and they were just
talking about bishop g5 right so it does
make sense for them to want to stop it
so
what do you think we should do as white
we can no longer play bishop g5
so b4 is not so unreasonable now
right
and my opponent played a5 now
i went for simple moves
i didn't want to dissolve anything in
this side because if i take i'm giving
them a weakness
and i'm
not really doing myself any favor so b5
knights moves
and now
what do you think is a good move for
whites
so just to do a tiny recap we talked
about the bishop g5 we talked about the
b4 option and then we talked we're
currently talking about what if opponent
actually actively takes away
the bishop g5 option
exactly knight takes d4
beautiful my opponent took over here
which i don't fully support i think
bishop g4 would have been more tricky to
develop first a little bit and then do
that so you kind of got like a move with
the tempo out there just a little bit
i i have extra pawn so i'm happy about
the position but opponent still has nice
piece activity
a lot of targets that they can go after
so
all right so
um what if knight takes d3
say we take
opponent here played
queens and i was thinking bishop g4 but
they if they wanted bishop g4 they
should have done it with tempo the
previous move so they they went queen c7
let's just develop
this should be an easy game right
because we just won a pawn
and we have a nice bishop
so this should be fine
and it was actually pretty easy game
so what do you think we should do as
white how can you keep this advantage
and convert it to a win
just push cpan i kinda like that that's
what i did too simple moves
queen out i just developed
bishop out sure
you shove away all right cool let's
exchange queens simplify the position c5
seems to be a better choice but i just
want to kind of get rid of these
so opponent did not accept the queen
exchange offer they went back i tried to
relocate some of my pieces there we go
created beautiful
diagonal and file over there
okay i don't know why i did that
actually
i was thinking i should activate this
trick
so maybe bishop move to try to exchange
off
oh actually i know why i did that i was
not ready to give up on the attack on
the king side where i clearly have an
advantage in the queen side
the right now dorsal would be very happy
to just chill and you know play in the
queen side advance there and when there
but
five six years ago dorsal really really
wanted the king so
i went queen e3
and the opponent didn't disappoint me
that's the beauty of it
and ah
nice this is a fun ending so why timo
what do you think we should do right now
again this was a generous opponent
so why to move what do we do after that
we're going to talk about one more line
thank you man or from
knight a4 yep and this is just
beautifully painful
i don't know if those two words actually
go together it's beautiful for me
painful for them so
yeah knight b6 you can't really stop it
and that's where my opponent resigned i
think actually this game was in uh yeah
it wasn't reykjavik i wasn't having a
good tournament in reykjavik i was sick
and i was just not doing well but this
game i liked one of my biggest regrets
is i was in reykjavik and i should have
taken one round off to go see fisher's
resting place and i didn't so this is a
big regard of mine i would actually like
to go back and do that so if you do go
to reykjavik
do see that historical site because
i didn't and i regret regretted okay
now one thing i wanted to talk about is
this bishop c5
what do we do here
it's called the cobra
nice
if you like cobras
actually no i'm not a big fan of snakes
all right
they're pretty but far far away
hello lewis oh wait are you the lewis
who was here a few few weeks back
actually a few months back
there we go skull yep bishop f4
uh it was a friendly game but i played
knight d6 and i was
punished really badly it still hurts a
little the opponent went king e7 then i
played bishop f4 e5 check king back i'm
i it still looks like white is fine
right
white is not
not fine but at the same time opponent
has a much easier time with their
position
i tried to be cute and i got really
punished i should have just went for
like bishop c4
but this is also too
boring like opponent just lost their
castling right there should be something
there right
but that's not how it just works it's
not how life works
so
i wanted to like show my opponent like
you played it wrong i got this
but that didn't really i didn't really
and they didn't really this is a totally
fine opening
now opponents could have made it harder
on me by bishop before already or by
like h5 right now but that it was it
wasn't that serious of a game and we
weren't playing for a
championship and i don't think they gave
it their hundred percent neither did i
but i managed to mess it up i lost a
beautiful tactic here so i'm going to
ask for you to find it white to move how
can whites
um
continue this
opponent just did a mini tactic
if queen d5 queen ashford check
good luck with that
what else you got
beautiful queenish five i agree now blah
white is actually winning
because if pawn move all right we'll
take that we'll attack in that you move
this now i have long castle attack
attack attack everywhere
right
so i messed up i didn't play queenish
live i just
i think this isn't a blitz i don't even
remember if it was a blitz or not but i
know that i was very hurt after this
game because i know i had a shot and i
really messed it up the game went on for
some more moves and i just lost it
but um
the point being that
yeah think of intermediate moves this
would have been a beautiful in-between
move intermediate move all right so now
let's go back and i want to tell you the
right way of playing after bishop c5 it
is not knights d6
96 is certainly a possibility but please
don't make your opponent happy don't
walk into what they want bishop before
is it
and the idea is if you play e5 well
thank you this is a permanent weakness
you do no longer you no longer have d5
ideas so
hallelujah for me
and to top it all off let's set up on
castles now what do we do
sicilian fixing the weaknesses i like
that that's a good one i'm going to use
that
fragrance you know this opening um
particularly well
how and why
do you play this
so i see a lot of people are suggesting
stuff to happen on d6 i'm gonna say yes
but not just yet
the better option is to play bishop c7
let's say queen moves
then we have bishop d6 then take we take
if they take we take and this bishop is
just like
how do you plan to deal with this
next you're gonna do long castle you are
gonna try to fixate well not that far ah
fixate over here
this will be pretty nice
oh you play this as black okay fragrance
that makes a lot of sense
no wonder you know the swell
so
yeah this would have been fun
uh bishop c7 they are not obligated to
take the queen though they have this
like weird kind of cool 98
take take and then this again i'm going
to continue saying weird slash cool
because these nights are just weird but
i do no longer have the night ideas
myself
so
now opponents can try to get funny with
their pawns maybe like a6
knight d6
dwight still holds advantage but it's
not that
amazing anymore
so that's another i just wanted to
mention that line for bishop c5 to make
sure to do this bishop f4
and if opponent castles this bishop c7
and then bishop d6 don't go 96
because i actually recently played this
with another student
and i think i accidentally went bishop
d6 and they played queen b6 and they got
really uncomfortable so be careful with
that as well
let's see there are other lines that i
would obviously like to talk about but
we don't have the time however i'm gonna
actually talk about
one
game that was kind of cool
actually how it was like oh my god eight
years ago
uh but i do want to talk about this game
really quickly because it was a weird
line and today we're doing weird lines
we have graduated from the
fortnite sicilian but i do want to talk
about
this weird thing right here because it's
about the square so i just wanted to put
them all together
all right let's think about this
why to move what should we do
jonathan is asking how much is chess
part of
how much is psychology part of chess
well let me answer it this way
for the whole class i've been kind of
talking about you know not making your
opponent comfortable i might have
actually used the word torturing the
opponent
at least i know i said annoying the
opponents so um
we're talking we're not just talking
about the the chess moves they're also
talking about how to get into your
opponent's head how how not to just play
the game but play the opponents we're
talking about a lot of these of course
you're gonna need chess skills to be
able to do those but if you're not
thinking about the opponent you're not
playing chess
so
i hope that answers a question
of how much psychology is part of chess
without psychology you're not going to
have that great of a chess game
you can do puzzles i think because you
actually have to think about
the actually puzzles you still have to
think about opponents
you can probably do maintain once
without thinking about what the
opponents can do because they can't do
anything
yeah
all right
there's a question how do we send in a
game not just yet we're gonna do that in
our twitch channel shortly
okay this is the final game that we're
gonna look and it's relatively short so
you got this
i went for i agree with bishop g5
the one i did bishop g5 this knight p3
is also a thing which should be two is
the thing but i kind of just wanted to
go for you know
more
oomph
all right
so opponents played queen c7 this just
is a stinky how do we how do we
show them who's the boss
my cat does that to me just constantly
shows me he's the boss so
i've picked up on that
ah there you go let's go for sacrifice
there you go yep yep yep take take
opponents gave check
i played bishop back
there
there
there okay now what did we do
to be fair i had this prepared before
the game because i i didn't find this
over the board maybe i should have left
that detail out and i just said how
beautiful brain i have and over the
board i just found this amazing line i
i'm not gonna lie about that no
i um i had it prepared before the game
because i
saw what she played and i
prepared it that's why i think you
should be prepared as much as you can
figure out what your opponent wants to
play and just prepare for it
it's like knowing it's like when the
teachers like tell you hey by the way
i'm gonna have this question on the exam
please have an answer ready for it and
if you don't have an answer ready for it
then you're just
you know
not doing what you should so
yeah 96 beautiful check this is a
possibility
but
my heart was with queen b3 because i
just wanted to eat their queen
so
opponent played 95 just trying to stop
that of course i ate the knight i'm not
gonna say no to a knight they took here
and then i just won the queen
the rest
i'm just gonna kind of
skim through
because it was too beautiful
there you go
all right
let's open up some files let's get the
bishop in a better spot
get the rooks rolling
there we go
opponents is still fighting it's it's
still two pieces it's not super easy i
still have to be cautious
there you go speaking of caution
and opponent resign after that because
if they were to take
i had this beautiful this was not a part
of preparation this i will say
uh it would be too cool if i had that as
a preparation
but no this was actually truly opening
disaster for black
um
i
yeah this was this was a lot of fun so
we looked at some truly weird openings
for white uh
that white could encounter
so
uh that sicilian fortnite is not
truly weird but it can get weird as we
just saw with like a lot of things in
kingside happening a lot of things in
queenside happening
um
next week we're gonna actually look into
more
classy lines
not super weird stuff we're gonna look
at more
um con paulson
there are some weird lines there too but
we're gonna keep it there i'm assuming
then we're gonna do a little chevron
engine and then come to najdorf and then
after that we're gonna talk decide which
to do after but next week it is going to
be
classy stuff so
be prepared
and with that i think i'm gonna wrap it
up
uh it's a pleasure being here i'm gonna
actually see most of you soon on our
twitch channel so
yeah
search to twitch
[Music]
you